we're looking at today yeah chances
again for storms this has just been an
unbelievable monsoon season it's been
great for us it's kind of like the old
days the way it used to be
but we've got beautiful skies this
morning we've got clouds over the
mountains it's super muggy out there dew
points in the mid 60's humidity
averaging about 75 percent we'll look to
the mountains again in fact western
clark county over tonight county and
down into san bernardino and over into
inyo counties those areas may have the
best chances for flooding today with
heavy thunderstorms lots of 70s around
this morning still around 80 in green
valley 81 downtown 69 out at red rock
red rock is included in a flash flood
watch area where we could get some heavy
rain again through the spring mountains
over to perron trump at 73 sandy valley
73 we've got 74 at indian springs near
80 in mesquite upper 70s for boulder
city nice 70 degrees in searchlight this
morning 82 in loughlin 73 up in reno
reno hit 100 yesterday 103 on saturday
and 104 back on friday so let's tally up
the rain totals from friday to sunday
not that impressive officially at 15
hundredths of an inch and for the year
not quite an inch yet but two and a half
inches where we should be there are so
many neighborhoods that have gotten that
much and more just in daily rain totals
down around sun city anthem that area
seven hills got clobbered yesterday
before noontime again and the southeast
valley anywhere from the beltway over to
green valley look at that a quarter of
an inch to over half an inch and then
areas on the west side only like four
hundredths of an inch a third of an inch
up in the mountains but boy you go over
to mohave county down in golden valley
in that area south of willow beach two
inches of rain yesterday so some of
these thunderstorms have the potential
for dropping some very very heavy rain
we'll look for that potential again this
afternoon and again with rotation that
we're seeing
on the satellite imagery we can tell
that inyo county and another area south
has the potential for spinning out some
very big thunderstorms dropping heavy
rain today that's where we see the flash
flood watches so those are in place
until 10 o'clock tonight so western
clark county in tonight county and over
there into california we'll be watching
for possibly very heavy rainfall more
heat in the northwest and the central
part of the u.s and that's tropical
storm frank there that's spinning
parallel to baja we don't expect it to
turn inland and bring us any hurricane
rains tropical rains but could be a
player later in the week 97 for the high
that's a 40 chance of showers and
thunderstorms this afternoon into
tonight only 10 chance tomorrow and then
a break midweek but then the pattern
comes right back by thursday through the
weekend
you'll see that 20 25 percent chance of
storms again as we head into our first
weekend of august